[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
nous retrouver pour ce 7 8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département à ces
parties a pour le sommaire handball le
club de plaisir aux sauver l'entente pcn
pour le choc de la 19e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 et les
plaisirs oies se sont inclinés sur le
score de 33 à 24 un résultat lourd de
conséquences plus explications à suivre
dans ce magazine football billancourt
been fin de saison palpitante à la lutte
pour le podium en terre de district
légumes pour toi disputeront également
la finale de la coupe des yvelines début
juin coup de projecteur dans quelques
instants
tir à l'arc ou compétition sélective
pour les championnats de france a réuni
plus de 150 archers ce samedi à montigny
le bretonneux avec au programme des tirs
olympique longue distance de 70 m poids
pour les arcs classiques
reportage à suivre on ouvre maintenant
une page résultats
[Musique]
on commence donc ce magazine par du
handball plaisir elle n'y arrive plus
dans le championnat de nationale 3
domicile et plaisir aux ans concédé leur
troisième défaite sur quatre matches
disputés contre l'entente pcn le score
est sévère 33 à 24 ans montage de xavier
jaglin le score au tableau d'affichage
est lourd ce dimanche 13 mai plaisir
s'incline à domicile 33 24 dans une
rencontre où les jaune et noir n'ont
jamais pu trouver la solution face à
l'entente pelé cnc genre de match voilà
faut vraiment être à 200 % si on veut
remporter à la moindre relâchement et on
prend trois quatre buts d'écart et un
deuxième relâchement et voilà on termine
à moins 9
mais bon les scènes mérite amplement
cette du temps mais je savais que
c'était un match un match difficile on
avait perdu à l'aller chèque c'est une
bonne équipe
aucun fond de jeu cohérent donc je
m'attendais à un match difficile mais
après on s'attend jamais à à perdre
cette troisième défaite en quatre
matches disputés dans le championnat de
nationale 3 fait redescendre plaisir à
la quatrième place
une spirale négative dans le sprint
final qui peut s'expliquer par le nombre
de blessés dans les rangs plaisir war
c'est sûr que cette année on a un
effectif qui fait que si on perd un ou
deux joueurs
sur des postes clés voilà on a un
déficit sur le point de vue défensif ou
les dispositifs qu on a line sont pas
les dispositifs pour l'aligner
habituellement donc forcément on essaye
de trouver des solutions là où
finalement il n'a peut-être pas et voilà
mais bon c'est juste parce qu'on essaye
de rester compétiteurs jusqu'au bout et
de se battre avec nos armes
l'entraîneur victor garrigues espère
récupérer un maximum de joueurs d'ici le
prochain match programmé ce dimanche 20
mai à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
saint sébastien sport avec toujours un
objectif en tête
accrocher une place de barragiste à la
fin de la saison après plaisir en
continue à parler de handball l'équipe
féminine de montigny le bretonneux se
déplaçait ce samedi soir sur le terrain
du club municipal d'aubervilliers pour
le compte de la 20e journée du
championnat de nationale 2 et les îles
monteyne sont repartis de ce déplacement
avec une défaite dans leurs valises le
score 31 à 27
une défaite qui n'a pas d'incidence au
classement montigny le bretonneux est
toujours à l'avant dernière place du
championnat mais ne descendra pas cette
année grâce à la nouvelle réforme et
reste deux journées à montigny le
bretonneux pour sauver l'honneur
on ouvre une page football américain à
présent pour leur dixième et dernier
match de la saison régulière de deuxième
division les templiers d'elancourt ont
été inspirés ce samedi soir à domicile
et l'ont emporté 19 à 6 contre les
diables rouges de villepinte
cette sixième victoire de la saison
permet aux élans courtois d'accéder aux
playoffs
ils affronteront en demi finale de
conférence les corsaires d'evry pour
continuer à croire à une montée en fin
de saison on écoute la réaction par
téléphone du nouveau président des
templiers à joël à da silva façon
c'était l'objectif qu'on s'était fixés
déjà depuis le début de saison c'était
aux minimes 1 l'accession aux play-offs
pour ensuite jouer la finale de
conférence nord donc on est carrément
dans le plan de route qu'on s'était fixé
en début de saison pour nous c'est
mérité malgré une saison qui qui a
relevé quelques os est certes un petit
bas pour se serait bien passé c'est une
négation pure que totalement amérique
après le football américain du soccer
avec le championnat de national troyes
versailles a remporté ce dimanche après
midi une victoire importante sur son
teint contre colombes 92 la 12e de la
saison les versaillais l'ont emporté sur
la plus petite des marges 1 à 0 au
classement les joueurs de la cité royale
ne sont plus qu'à deux petits points de
la deuxième
détenus par aubervilliers à une journée
de la fin du championnat
encore du football mais cette fois ci
quelques étages plus bas en première
division de district une équipe est en
train de vivre une fin de saison
palpitante kim est en effervescence tout
un club du en cours est actuellement à
la lutte pour monter sur le podium et
pourrait également voir sa saison
récompensée par un titre en coupe des
yvelines 3 juin prochain pour nous
parler de cette excellente dynamique
nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président guy gallant ti et le coach
jude talent amoureuse bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de parler de classement de
coupe davis nous allons parler du match
de ce week-end contre l'épaule 4 à 0
c'est un festival
ce week-end un jeune oui c'était un
festival disons que on est sur une bonne
dynamique en ce moment donc une victoire
largement méritée avec un groupe qui
serait très très bien et qui est très
très performant en ce moment qu'est-ce
qui a fait la différence sur cette
rencontre
c'est là notre solidarité notre sérieux
aussi donc les joueurs sont très
concernés et puis je pense qu'après
individuellement et intrinsèquement avec
des joueurs au dessus de l'épaule et
poney on peut le dire quasiment
relégable là vous me sens sur la 16e
championnat sur cette saison ils ont
acheté des produits en cours said on
s'est rendu le match facile parce que on
a ouvert le score très tôt et très vite
on a été supérieurs pratiquement dans
tous les domaines que ce soit technique
technique athlétique
je crois que très vite on a fait la
différence est aussi un paramètre
important pour votre équipe on avait
perdu qu'une seule fois sur une défaite
qui pour le moment
nous fait un petit peu mal mais sont un
match que je pense qu'on méritait la
victoire mais ce jour l heure environ
ça ne voulait pas rentrer il ya des
jours comme ça donc c'est un petit peu
dommage oui pour le moment
alors vous avez un bilan de 12 victoires
3 nuls et 5 défaites pour 39 points
engrangés depuis le début de la saison
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est la
saison idéale parfaite pour but
encourage une l'a dit la saison idéale
non parce que je pense qu'il ya cinq
défaites en oui oui cinq défaites contre
des adversaires de bas de classement en
plus donc du coup on est un peu déçu là
dessus mais on fait une deuxième partie
très intéressante l'année 2018 nous et
bien favorable pour le moment on a on a
bien redressé la barre et puis en
espèces j'espère surtout bien terminée
il ya lentement l'expliquez vous
justement c'est ses cinq défaites et
notamment contre les petits du
championnat on va se dire que lui en
course a subi dans les grands rendez
vous est peut-être un petit peu moins
dans les rendez vous on va dire un peu
plus prenable ben peut-être mais je
crois pas que ça soit le seul indicateur
je crois que c'est notre entame de
championnat est toujours difficile
depuis quelques saisons et on termine
toujours très fort mais voilà on n'a pas
l'équipe le saturer me déterminer en
début de saison on la découvre petit à
petit
et après on se rend compte que le
saturer une fois qu'elle est créée et
elle est très forte elle vous plaît
cette équipe a oui beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé il ya beaucoup
de jeunes déjà du club
donc ce qui est très important et je
crois que bien entouré par quelques
anciens maintenant et puis par le coach
a maintenant qu'à la mienne regroupant
20 kg de physiquement comment sentez
vous vos troupes
on est en fin de championnat les
organismes sont souvent fatigué oui mais
mal mais on est très très bien sur notre
fin de championnat physiquement on
travaille on travaille très très bien
les joueurs sont très assidus au niveau
des entraînements donc déjà c'est un
paramètre important surtout sur la fin
de saison ou en général on perd un peu
de joueurs mais tout le monde est bien
est concernée puis on fait un travail on
va dire physique important sur les
séances et puis les joueurs adhèrent et
puis il en redemande donc ce qui fait
qu'on termine très bien les matches là
dessus pour le moment n'a pas de soucis
vous n'avez pas alléger vos séances on a
allégé un petit peu mais
avec quand même travail conséquent où
les joueurs sont présents il travaille
très très bien hélas trois matches à
jouer dont deux en championnat ce ça va
le faire physiquement pour vos troupes
physiquement je n'ai pas de crainte donc
je pense qu'on a bien terminé là dessus
il ya vraiment pas de souci et puis on a
un groupe aussi de 18 à 20 joueurs aussi
qui nous permet aussi de bien au pouvoir
terminer la saison je pense alors on
voit le classement justement en
championnat vous êtes actuellement donc
dans le top 4 du classement
vous pensez pouvoir terminer à quelle
place qui garantit moi ce que je
souhaiterais c'est terminé deux fois qui
est à seulement deux petits points qui
voient leurs arguments cours du pecq
alors nous on va pour la première
rencontre hardricourt cheney donc aussi
7e et donc en rond et on espère bien
terminer la saison et avoir plutôt du
haut de tableau donc ça devrait réussir
à guyancourt
voilà j'espère bon maintenant le
football étant ce qu'il est on a vu des
herbiers a qui dispute une finale de
coupe de france et qui descendent donc
voyez que rien n'est joué en foot mais
bon on a beaucoup d'espoir je vous avais
fixé un objectif de points sur ces
dernières rencontres oui on le voit on
s'est fixé c'est de terminer là il nous
reste deux matches de prendre les six
points et puis après on a une belle
finale à jouer aussi en coupe des
yvelines contre une belle équipe de
maurepas donc on espère faire une belle
fête sur cette fin de saison et donc
l'objectif qu'on s'était fixé en 2018
c'est un maximum de victoires sur ce
qu'on arrive à faire jusqu'à présent
justement cette coupe des yvelines alors
vous avez battu le 1er avril ce n'était
pas une blague
hardricourt sur le score de 5 buts à 1
ce parcours est et il a tendu oui parce
que les joueurs les joueurs sont sont
très concernés par la coupe et il met
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
à beaucoup de détermination là dessus
donc il n'y a pas de surprise je suis
vraiment pas surpris là dessus la
motivation est naturelle et puis les
joueurs adhèrent exactement et à cette
coupe qu'ils adorent parce qu'on sait
que c'est une coupe qui nous réussit
bien il ya quelques années il ya deux
ans on a fait un super parcours et
depuis les war an une joie de retrouver
cette coupe chaque année le président at
il fixé
je sais pas une prime de victoire non
non non non non pas du tout non je mange
disque luxe a fait largement oui c'est
un objectif bien sûr mais c'est les
coupes les matchs de coupe
je crois que c'est plutôt un engagement
individuel et collectif à la fois mais
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
particulier qui est complètement
différent du championnat
donc vous allez affronter maurepas en
finale une équipe qui a sorti plaisir
aux tirs au but
vous serez favori sur cette rencontre
voilà dynamique de guyancourt et la
dynamique de maurepas oui sur la
dynamique oui mais je pense que mort
près c'est une équipe très très vraiment
soirée puis on on s'apprécie beaucoup
entre les coaches et puis les joueurs
aussi se connaissent donc je pense qu'il
n'ya pas fort il n'ya pas vraiment un
favori sur ce sont sur ces deux finales
je pense que chacun aura sa chance et
même si on l'a emmené sans une dynamique
on va dire plus en plus intéressantes
sur la fin de saison que mort pas mais
c'est une équipe qui lâche rien et qui
va s'accrocher jusqu'au bout je pense à
présent on a toujours fait une belle
finale contre on avait peur on avait
perdu au penalty il ya trois ans en
trois ans on les retrouve
bon j'espère que cette fois ci le sort
sera favorable à guyancourt mais voilà
c'est une belle équipe c'est bien bon
éducateur et d'en bas je souhaite que
lui encore gagnante et la manière ah non
pas que la manière nous on y fait très
attention un mine de rien on pratique un
beau jeu depuis tous les matches retour
merci à tous les deux est passé sur ce
plateau je rappelle la finale de la
coupe d i mean ce sera le 3 juin
prochain à maisons laffitte à l'opposera
à maurepas à guyancourt
on continue à parler de football un
tournoi pour les moins de 11 ans et les
moins de 13 ans était organisée ce
week-end au stade guy-boniface
d'elancourt
au total ces équipes dont 2 100 %
féminine et plus de 350 jeunes de la
région étaient présents pour ce rendez
vous chez les u11 c'est le club de
valenton qui s'est illustré et chez les
u 13 c rambouillet qui remporte la
victoire cet événement avait été
rebaptisée
chauveau en hommage à l'un des
dirigeants emblématiques du club
d'elancourt décédé en septembre dernier
en basket deux joueurs de l'entente le
chesnay versailles ont brillé en
sélection ile de france ce week end
laisse la saint-quentinoise diana est
devenue championne de france avec la
sélection féminine et a survolé la
finale en inscrivant 18 points et pris à
13 rebonds des performances qui vont lui
permettre d'aller à l'insep en septembre
prochain de son côté hugo nyamé langues
d'ici est devenu également champion de
france en finale il a marqué 12 points
et pris 11 rebonds
eux aussi ont l'habitude de régler à la
mire à une compétition de tir à l'arc
était organisée tout au long du week-end
au stade de la coudre à montigny le
bretonneux avec au programme des tirs
sur les distances olympiques l'ont
rendez-vous attiré 150 sportifs qui
n'ont pas hésité à braver la pluie pour
pratiquer leur sport des images de à
nicolas d'henri 150 archers ont passé un
test olympique ce samedi 12 mai pour la
troisième fois la compagnie de tir à
l'arc de montigny le bretonneux
organisait une compétition individuelle
sélective pour les championnats de
france avec au programme la mythique
barre des 70 mètres distance inscrite
aux jo dans la mesure en fait on va
rajouter 20 m et bien c'est déjà plus
difficile pour l'arche est donc de bien
tenir son arc et donc d'avoir le même
niveau de précision
on fait toujours les mêmes erreurs on
essaye d'en faire un petit peu moins
quand même mais ça pardonne beaucoup
plus donc toutes les erreurs qu'on peut
faire sur des distances plus rapprochés
sont un résultat amplifiée en cible donc
un oeuf plus rapprochée peut être ainsi
sous 1,5 à 77 ans plus de la distance
olympique les archers ont dû affronter
le vent et la pluie pendant une grande
partie de l'après midi
on doit tirer partout en
il ya juste la grêle ou les éclairages
qui nous arrête sinon que celui face 45
degrés ou qui pleuvent à foison on tire
on est là la pluie fait descendre des
flèches en tombant dessus en en vises un
petit peu plus haut et on croise les
doigts pour que ça suffise rendez vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition les espérons que la météo soit
plus clémente cette fois ci on ouvre
maintenant une large page golf belle
surprise pour le à chênée open de france
est presque officiel le nouveau numéro
un mondial est très médiatique justin
thomas ce sera au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du 28 juin au
1er juillet pour participer au rolex
series se condense surnomme jti est un
poids lourds du circuit américain le
sportif a notamment remporté 7 titres
depuis octobre 2016 il a également été
l'un des piliers de l'équipe américaine
vainqueur de la dernière ryder cup
justin thomas sera fort à faire pour ce
rendez-vous il devra s'employer face au
vainqueur de l'an passé tommy fleetwood
et l'espagnol john rabe numéro quatre
mondial la nouvelle devrait être
annoncée officiellement demain dans la
journée
les français seront également au
rendez-vous de cette 102e édition de
l'open de france de golf michael
lorenzo-vera troisième l'année dernière
sera de retour sur l'albatros grégory
bourdy quadruple vainqueur sur le
circuit européen sera également de la
partie
romain à vatel à raphaël jacquelin et
grégory havret ont également confirmé
leur venue est celui qui va susciter
beaucoup d'espoir pour une victoire
finale le dimanche ce sera alexander
levy
le numéro un français sera bien sur les
greens saint quentinois ans jean
prochain on écoute sa réaction
easterly nice-corse russe
le parcours est vraiment très beau c'est
l'un des plus beaux à mes yeux che allah
de le disputer
c'est l'un des plus beaux rendez vous au
moins jouer à donner implique un peu de
pression tu as eu le plaisir de jouer
devant ses supporters interview fans une
victoire lui permettrait de se
rapprocher de l'objectif de sa saison
faire partie de l'équipe européenne de
la ryder cup en septembre prochain
à noter également la non pressent
présence du chouchou du public français
à victor dubuisson blessé ne pourra pas
prendre part au tournoi à saint
quentinois l'open de france de golf qui
se déroulera sur le même parcours que la
ryder cup 2018 on commence d'ailleurs à
y voir un peu plus clair sur
l'encadrement de l'équipe européenne à
moins 2
mois de l'événement alors qu'on pensait
voir un vice capitaine français sur les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines en septembre prochain
le danois thomas bjorn va finalement
nommé deux tricolores comme assistant
leur nom raphaël jacquelin et grégory
havret deux quarantenaires du circuit
européen qui dispute chaque année de
nombreux tournois dont l'open de france
de golf on l'a entendu précédemment mais
qui n'ont aucune expérience en ryder cup
sur les greens et de français auront
notamment pour mission de faire le lien
entre les membres du staff le public et
la presse ils pourront également
accompagné des joueurs sur le parcours
on continue à parler de golf et de la
ryder cup vous en avez désormais
l'habitude tous les lundis tv 60,18 vous
propose de découvrir les moments qui ont
marqué l'histoire de la compétition
aujourd'hui le directeur adjoint du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
philippe pilato nous présente l'un de
ses souvenirs
regardez je me souviens de la ryder cup
en fait de ryder cup de deux moments de
moment c'est ryder cup a médina
mais villa donc aux états unis en fait
ce qui se passe
départ de doubler dans les doubles en
fait vous savez
dans le golfe il ya toujours au moment
où c'est comme au tennis au moment où le
joueur c'est rodolphe c'est au moment où
il va taper sa balle il ya toujours un
silence on entend les mouches tournée et
en fait je sais pas ce qui prend à yanbu
pas ian poulter ian poulter au lieu
d'avoir ce silence sur départ du trou
numéro un là on le voit un petit peu se
retourner vers la foule faire des
moments et en fait qui demandait c'était
à la foule le faire de plus en plus de
bruit et long ça c'était génial parce
qu'on avait vous aviez autour du départ
je sais pas à peu près dix mille
spectateurs qui hurlent et fit chanter
crier us puisque c'était plutôt de de
l'autre côté de l'atlantique et donc là
donc
ian poulter qui tape le coup en face
bien évidemment l'équipe américaine n'a
pas voulu rester là dessus et donc bubba
watson a fait exactement la même chose
c'est-à-dire a motivé la foule de façon
de faire de plus en plus de bruit de
plus en plus de plus en plus c'est donc
là c'était exactement ce moment là c'est
pas y'a que dans la ryder cup où on peut
avoir des moments aussi aussi atypique
est exceptionnel ceux ci avaient été
renouvelés à gleneagles sur la ryder cup
de 2014 ou bubba watson
avait demandé au public écossais de
faire énormément de bruit au moment où
vous tapez sa balle et dans les journaux
il était étonné parce que il s'attendait
à avoir un peu de monde qu'elle et
l'encourager et ce moment là pour moi ça
a été
c'est un moment un moment inoubliable
exceptionnel parce que pareil c'est
beaucoup d'émotion et les choses voilà
atypique exceptionnel qu'on trouvera que
sur une ryder cup
[Musique]
on poursuit ce magazine par notre agenda
du week-end ce samedi dimanche sera
organisé pour la toute première fois la
coupe de france de kung fu à guyancourt
un rendez vous qui devrait réunir
plusieurs centaines de sportifs pour
nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons sur ce plateau des membres du
club de kung fu wushu du dragon noir
le professeur principal stéphane molard
et deux sportifs du club
anna-maria dinh huê reid a décalé de
cali alors déjà avant de parler de
l'événement est ce qu'on pourrait me
présenter le kung fu alors le congrès
c'est l'art martial chinois
donc ça comporte des techniques
demain deux jambes de projection et de
clés donc ça ça se
montre de façon différente donc au
niveau compétition il ya deux parties
bien distinctes et la technique qu'on
appellera au loup donc c'est des
enchaînements pour les enfants et les
adultes
on doit pratiquer au moins deux
enchaînements à mains nues et un avec
arme
on combine les deux notes et puis le
total des notes permet un classement par
catégorie d'âge ensuite il ya la partie
combat donc pour les adultes ça
s'appelle le standard ou au sedif plein
contact et pour les enfants s'appellent
du tchinda ou là les coups au visage
sont prohibés mais ils sont bien
protégés ils ont des casques des
plastrons et tout ce qu'il faut et vous
vous allez participer du coup à la
compétition qu'est ce que vous allez
présenter lors de la compétition
moi je vais présenter un enchaînement de
sabre et un enchaînement de mon mieux et
moi pareil en enchaînements savoir un
enchaînement menu est ce que ce n'est
pas trop dangereux
bocoum fond on entend souvent à la
télévision que c'est dangereux est-ce
que c'est dangereux ou pas non parce
qu'en fait c'est dangereux
quand on fait pas attention mais quand
on fait attention c'est pas beau monde
dont jours va bien pratique et c'est pas
dangereux
vous vous permet bien sûr en tout cas
c'est on encadre bien les enfants on les
prépare bien
ensuite on leur inculque une certaine
façon de faire il arrive à contrôler ses
mouvements oui on contrôle
on maîtrise bien les mouvements ensuite
avec les armes
il ya de temps en temps quelques petits
incidents on va dire des petites
coupures et choses comme ça mais bon en
général ça se passe bien parce qu'on
travaille beaucoup d'exercice avant de
faire des enchaînements justement pour
qu'ils maîtrisent bien la remet donc là
ils vont présenter effectivement du main
nue et du sabre ils sont arrivés tous
les deux troisièmes au championnat
régional d'île de france et dont la de
voir ta chance de médaille des fortes
chances je ne sais pas en tout cas ce
que je leur ai dit comme aux autres
parce qu'ils sont six en tout à
participer je leur ai dit qu'il fallait
qu'il fasse le la plus belle prestation
qu'ils peuvent et puis on verra bien les
notes
ou on est à domicile donc on espère
qu'on aura beaucoup de public pour venir
les encourager
et puis bon le principal c'est qu'ils se
fassent plaisir et qui donne du plaisir
aux gens qui viennent les voir et
pourquoi ça organisé avec lui en trop
alors c'est la toute première fois on va
c'est la toute première fois alors
pourquoi parce que déjà
moi je fais partie de la commission
nationale douche ou au sein de la
fédération française de karaté qui nous
héberge et donc j'ai pu avec mes
contacts à la mairie pouvoir organiser
cet événement qui est quand même un
événement assez important puisqu'il ya à
peu près 300 enfants au moins 300
enfants qui vont venir de la france
entière
en plus donc ça ça va se passer
principalement le dimanche le dimanche
le matin on devrait faire toute la
partie technique
l'après midi la partie combat est par
contre le samedi également un événement
important
le matin il ya les sélectifs pour les
championnats du monde juniors qui vont
se dérouler à brasilia au brésil au mois
de juillet donc là ça concerne des
enfants un peu plus grands qui sont des
minimes et des cadets malheureusement il
n'y a pas de guyancourt toi mais bon
c'est pas grave ça permettra et vendre
éventuellement aux personnes qui veulent
venir de pouvoir avoir quand même un
beau spectacle parce que c'est quand
même assez impressionnant
et puis l'après midi du samedi il y aura
un stage national
encadrés par les entraîneurs nationaux
de table ou et 200 da pour tous les
compétiteurs non débutants donc ça c'est
un gros événement quand même pour la
pour la ville de guyancourt et on ne
peut pas venir
alors tout le monde peut venir voir bien
entendu l'entrée est gratuite
on attend de nombreuses personnes déjà
rien que les parents des enfants
ça doit faire beaucoup de choses à faire
beaucoup de monde et du coup vu que
c'est à domicile est ce que vous êtes
plus stressés vous voulez à les athlètes
est-ce que vous en parlez entre vous moi
personnellement non papus pas plus que
ça
j'avais l'habitude des compétitions oui
personnellement pas trop mais encore le
stress du trajet déjà et on n'a pas vu
que c'est juste à côté c'est plus simple
donc pouvoir se lever plus tard donc
c'est un avantage
c'est déjà un avantage justement vous
comptez réalisé des performances sur sur
cette compétition vous avez un objectif
de médailles peut-être nous enfin déjà
que si on pouvait ramener deux ou trois
médailles ça serait déjà très bien on a
la grippe est très bizarre mais
peut-être on sait jamais hein sait
jamais on sait jamais mais disons que
bon sur les 6 je pense qu'il y en a
trois qui peuvent prétendre
éventuellement à un podium
l'organisation ce type d'événement ça
fait forcément il ya une résonance on va
dire au niveau national oui est ce que
ça peut aider le club à avoir plus de
licenciés l'année prochaine ça peut ça
peut aujourd'hui on a déjà 150 licenciés
donc on s'est plaint pas de trop on
pourrait être toujours en avoir un petit
peu plus mais effectivement il ya des
chances que ça puisse nous ramener des
nouveaux adhérents
en tout cas vous allez en parler vous de
votre côté cette compétition on espère
vraiment à vos amis on espère qu'il ya
beaucoup de familles qui vont venir
encourager les jeunes c'est il faut en
profiter puisque c'est à domicile donc
c'est le moment de ramener plus de monde
merci à tous les trois le passé sur ce
plateau pour nous parler de cet
événement je vous rappelle que la coupe
de france de kung fu est organisée ce
samedi et dimanche à partir de 9 heures
au gymnase des droits de l'homme à
guyancourt
on referme ce magazine par deux autres
rendez vous qu'il ne faudra pas manquer
à ce week-end si vous êtes des
passionnés de sport local à guyancourt
un meeting en meeting d'athlétisme sont
organisées selon lee 18 mai au stade
maurice baquet au programme des
compétitions pour les benjamins et les
minimes de 18h à 20h30
l'événement est organisé par l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
autre rendez-vous à suivre en rugby et
l'équipe senior de versailles jouera ce
dimanche à 15h en 16e de finale du
championnat de france honneur contre le
rc haute bresse un événement très
important pour le club verser et qui
vise une montée en fédérale 3 dès cette
saison avec son groupe pour cela ils
devront passer ce match piège contre les
joueurs du département de l'ain
le lieu de la rencontre n'a pas encore
été communiquée à part la ligue
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi passé une excellente
semaine sportive sur tv 78 très belle
soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]